[Musik]
hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video arbeite
ich bin hier gerade im parkhaus von der
elbphilharmonie in hamburg ich weiß ich
die meisten von euch sollten das ja
wahrscheinlich kennen habt ihr bestimmt
war in der schule durchgenommen oder so
ich hab ja noch die kamera aus dem auto
geholt weil ich bock hatte dieses video
zu drehen wir sind nämlich diese nacht
in einem echt richtig coolen hotel ich
glaube das coolste teil in dem ich hab
so ein bisschen günstiger bekommen sonst
mache ich so was eigentlich auch nicht
und ich hatte einfach mal lust euch das
zu zeigen weil der ausblick wirklich
richtig geil dass man kann ganz hamburg
sehen und deswegen würde ich sagen gehen
wir jetzt mal hoch sagte er ich das mal
dass es wirklich ein bisschen
kompliziert nach oben zu kommen die
elbphilharmonie zeige ich euch gleich
auch noch mal von außen ist richtig
gigantisches gebäude so leicht dass
darum ist die elbphilharmonie von außen
also praktisch genau am wasser von unser
zimmer ist aber zu anderen seite im von
hier aus ich weiß nicht was sieht man
gar nicht wieder auf jeden fall echt
krass laußig werden euch das hier nehmen
noch mal ein foto ein
und ich würde sagen kommt man mit dahin
habe ich mein auto geparkt die stehen
aber auch echt richtig krass autos habe
ich mir eben auch schon einen korb dahin
haben wir ein rs 7 dann habe ich mir
eben auch angeguckt megacool freilich
auf den ersten
zugleich fährt man auf die achte etage
das ist schon relativ hoch da ist die
rezeption und die bar und so zeige ich
euch mal gleich wo ich will nämlich die
leute film also lassen wir mal sehr
unangenehm der auch zu saisonbeginn nach
oben das gibt mir ja schnell
ja da sind zu viele leute die man die
karte dran und wir haben unser zimmer
auf der 13 sowie die rezeption ist echt
cool man hat auch schon coolen ausblick
aber aus unserem zimmer ist ja noch mal
besser deswegen kein problem das ist
nicht so viele firmen konnte wir fahren
jetzt auf die 13 etage das 90
und wir sind hier im zimmer 28 also 1328
ich zeige euch das ziehen wir jetzt mal
genauso wie wir es vorgefunden haben
weil da kommt man noch gar nicht den
ausblick sehen und ja gehen wir mal rein
hier kommt die karte rein die andere
habe ich jetzt gerade noch eingesteckt
dann geht das licht an und wenn man dann
reinkommt sieht das erst mal so aus
eigentlich wie ein relativ normales
hotelzimmer würde ich mal sagen ein
bisschen größer vielleicht jetzt
vielleicht hat hier schon gesehen man
hat dir so ein fenster zum bad hin also
man kann die kette zeit ins bad cook
habe ich so auch noch nicht gesehen hier
sind die schränke haben wir sogar so ein
bügelbrett keine ahnung wieso dem
bügeleisen und die haben halt die
badeanzüge wie heißt noch mal bademantel
was hinter dieser tür hier ist 30 gar
nicht die geht auf jeden fall nicht hier
haben wir dann einen safe hier irgendwie
so dahin gläser und wein
hier ist die mini da ja eigentlich auch
ganz normal hier sind damit astra bier
ich glaube das kommt ja aus hamburg wenn
ich nicht ganz wird bin ich habe ich mir
gerade schon kaffee gemacht man muss
auch sagen es sieht sehr unordentlich
aus wir sind ja schon ein bisschen
länger und hier unten ist wahrscheinlich
gar nicht mehr gut also soviel erstmal
dazu das ist überhaupt nicht spektakulär
das kennt man ja so dann würde ich sagen
gehen mal kurz erstens bad also hier im
bad
mal weniger sich geschminkt dann haben
wir die badewanne und die badewanne ist
einfach direkt ja mit seinem glas dingen
zum bettchen dh man kann sich eigentlich
die ganze zeit beobachten wenn jemand
durch oder wenn jemand in berlin
das ist auch gar nicht so das ist auch
gar nicht sofort öffnen stell dir vor du
bist jetzt hiermit also da gibst du
schon nach weil ich damit ein problem
haben sagen das nur so sondern haben wir
hier die dusche die echt richtig schön
ist richtig dicker strahl das jetzt wenn
nötig kann ihr euch das mal an machen
[Musik]
da steht das war jetzt meine füße
schnell wieder raus hier das waschbecken
also alles was man so braucht ganz
normal
hier ist damit toilette also noch ein
wirklich stehen eingerichtetes bat das
muss man ganz ehrlich sagen jetzt marie
bis zum letzten kurs helfen solche
markiert jetzt die kamera lernen ich
würde sagen jetzt gehen wir mal zum
wichtigsten teil und zart zu dem
wohnraum also ist ja eigentlich nur
einen run und dann im ausblick also wir
sind ja auch extra gegangen und dachte
so ok warum sind jetzt die vorhänge vor
hier haben wir einmal ein wirklich
großes bett ja das ist auch super bequem
das hier ist der fernseher also ich sag
mal so an sich ist es ja wirklich ein
normales hotelzimmer bis jetzt also was
heißt normales und keine ahnung der ball
war ja dass mit der badewanne ist schon
cool aber bis auf den ausblick habe ich
das schon mal da will ich jetzt auch
nicht sagen
omega galt so es kommt man mit und zwar
haben wir hier einmal ein stuhl wo man
den ausblick genießen kann dann haben
wir gestern die vor allem aufgezogen
leider ist heute sehr schlechtes wetter
aber es ist mir egal
und das nicht nochmal vorhängen so dann
drückt man hier auf auto und dann gehen
diese folge auch auf und ich hoffe man
kann es auf der kamera erzählen aber wir
sind hier im 13 stock kann man das ding
geht ja bis zum 19
stock aber man kann schon sehen wir sind
hier fast somit auf einer der höchsten
stelle von hamburg und kann halt
komplett überholt sehen was ich hier
dann auch echt cool finde ich meinen
hätten jetzt ein zimmer zu der seite aus
könnte man komplett im hafen sehen aber
wir können hier einmal den hafen sehen
gestern abend wo es dunkel habe ich
leider nicht gefüllt ist die aida lang
gefahren dass er auch echt cool aus oder
halt ein aida und je 7 mannheim hamburg
ich glaube ja dass ist der hamburger dom
und irgendwas davon ist der hamburger
michael ich kenne ich jetzt leider haben
wir nicht so gut aus und hier komplett
herum sind halt dann die landungsbrücken
dann ist so ein kleiner kanal da habe
ich schon öfter mal so eine
hafenrundfahrt hier gestartet
und ja also es ist wirklich richtig cool
ich habe mich gestern richtig gefreut
über diesen ausblick von gestern hat
halt noch die sonne geschienen da hinten
haben wir gerade so ein containerschiff
das beladen wird nur die größere seite
vom hafen deshalb auf der anderen seite
ist aber auch gar nicht so schlimm
vom swimmingpool gestern konnte man auch
könig der löwen sehen das ist ja hier
dieses musical haben wir gestern auch
noch zusammen abgecheckt habe ich bisher
mit dem handy gefilmt ich würde sagen
zeig euch mal kurz ich weiß gar nicht ob
der ausstellung leute das hier ist ja
pool für das immer so lustig bin immer
der einzige wenn ich irgendwann mal
schwimmen wir sind auf jeden fall echt
cool aus der geht auch noch ganz schön
weit nach hinten und ich hab zwar
eigentlich auf gehabt dass man hier auch
irgendwie raus gucken kann kann man
leider nicht aber ist auch nicht so
schlimm ich ziehe jetzt hier ein
bisschen meine bahnen abends fort und
dann geht es wieder zurück aufs zimmer
tja leute also soviel zum zimmer mir
gefällt es richtig gut also es hat sich
auf jeden fall gelohnt das einfach mal
zu machen auch das personal und so hier
super nett also kann man auf jeden fall
mal empfehlen krieg dass wir kein geld
oder so das wird vielleicht am besten in
hamburg halt in der elbphilharmonie
ich glaube sogar ich bin mir jetzt nicht
sicher aber irgendwie hat mir das mal
zählt in diesem gebäude ganz irgendwo
ein klitschko kann das sein also genau
in dem gebäude ganz oben ich weiß jetzt
nicht ob man das gut auf der kamera sie
so leute jetzt ist gerade sogar noch mal
die sonne rausgekommen zumindest ein
bisschen also hier noch mal kurz ein
paar auflagen
[Musik]
ist auf jeden fall ein echter ausblick
das war es mit einem video wird
doch nach oben wir sehen uns dann am
sonntag wieder da gibt es wieder ein
normales video und ich hoffe die kleine
tour hat euch gefallen
und ja